So again, you got to ask yourself, why
do they always do this? It's not just
with this uh you know, like I said at
the beginning, I think um in a way this
series is just like a paradigm of
something I see all the time. Um I've
always liked sort of medieval movies. U
and I remember just from my youth always
liking them. And if you watch any of
them, okay, I challenge you. Go watch
especially big budget ones, famous ones,
there's always going to be a lot of
themes that will never change. Okay,
first of all, if you know anything about
the medieval era, it was a very hardcore
Christian time. Everywhere there were
crosses and icons and paintings and
everyone was making a sign of the cross
and you know the name of God and Christ
and everyone was on their mouth. Okay,
what whatever was in their heart, okay,
fine. But that was a permeated society.
Anytime you watch a movie now that's
about the medieval era, first of all,
you don't see any of that. And when you
do, okay, whoever is holding the cross,
whoever has the tiara on, whoever is uh
basically the religious guy, they are
always the most despicable characters.
Okay? Always. All right? Prove me wrong.
Any movie that's again medieval era. All
right? And why medieval era? Because
like I told you that was a time
where Christianity and mores were really
at a all-time high as far as a
civilization and cultural
expectations. Um but they always will
show you if you watch any movie. Uh okay
I'm trying to remember now because I
forget but okay how about Excalibur? I
used to like that movie right early 80s
I think. I like the movie but first of
all you wouldn't even know Christianity
exists. There's not a single cross, not
a single anything. It would have been
everywhere. All right. Um, and it's just
kind of like uh yeah, we're knights. The
whole idea of a knight is embedded and
tied with Christianity. To be a knight
without Christianity is completely
inconceivable, right? And yet they have
all these knights who are basically just
like secular warriors essentially. Um,
and that's and and that's just uh and
that's not even that bad, which is I'm
talking about Excalibur. But there's
Kingdom of Heaven, which I mentioned,
uh, which deals with the Crusades as
well.
And what's the opening scene? You know,
the the hero Ba Bale, that's actually a
historical figure, but of course, he's
mangled in the movie, but it's something
like some monk or some priest uh,
Baleian's wife is dead. Apparently, she
committed suicide and and the priest
cynically says she's going to hell. And
then later, Bailey sees him robbing her
cross. The priest robbing this dead
corpse's cross and kills him. Okay?
Because that's what that's what they do.
Everyone every anyone who's a Christian
is greedy, of course. Um and of and all
Saladin is sort of smart and shrewd, but
all the knights screaming Dale's vult
are stupid and caricatures and silly.
That's just um uh that's just um
Kingdom of Heaven. I'm I'm still
forgetting. Okay, how about um here's
another one I remember. Bewolf. You ever
seen the Beaolf movie, which is I don't
know like a cartoon. It came out maybe
like uh I don't know late 2000s
where I don't know what you call them.
This like cartoon movieish and it's it's
not as a movie it's not bad. And this is
supposed to be a time where paganism and
Christianity are sort of coming into
conflict and there's a tension between
them. And Beowolf, of course, is a is a
pagan at this time, even though in the
actual original text he's not. And
people say it's an interpolation, but
whatever. And um but there's one guy
who sort of starts off, he's kind of
this annoying character. I don't even
remember his name. If you watch it,
you'll know what I'm talking about. But
then he becomes a Christian because
Christianity reaches uh the northern
lands at this point and uh he becomes
just the most insufferable annoy. He
walks around with the cross. He's a
hypocrite. He beats his servant and he's
just a really distasteful person. So it
just never ever ever fails. I challenge
you next time you watch a movie that
deals with medieval history, medieval
Christianity, watch how the guy with the
cross is going to be portrayed. And I
guarantee you it's going to he's going
to be a very unsaavory, very
hypocritical person.
And uh I'm just wondering what's that
about?
Is that uh is that just ah uh I don't
know, we're trying to make a good movie
or is this part of a a long-term project
of sort of infiltrating and molding how
people think about Christianity? Because
if you think in the past all people were
like modern day whatever, well yeah,
that's going to justify you and that's
going to sort of convince and confirm
you to continue living that way. But if
you were to realize, oh, there was a
time when actually people who call
themselves Christians behaved like
Christians, not like atheists or
materialists,
um that you know we we don't want you to
realize that, okay? We want you always
to remember that anyone and everyone
throughout history were just like us and
even more so they were all committing
adultery. They were all sleeping around
all they were all homosexuals and
bisexuals and whatever. Okay. So I
personally am sick and tired of seeing
that in movies and um it's just because
it's so tiresome. It's so it's so
obviously agenda driven and uh it it's
uh so obviously meant to degrade men and
women because if you if they convince
you to think and believe this well
you're going to act that way. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire in the rightous
name.